are you drinking alcohol like old-school
alcohol that was mixed maybe in a
distillery or a winery or something like
that that is old school get new school
people it's now in powdered form the
alcohol tobacco tax and trade Bureau has
approved alcohol which is a powdered
alcoholic drink mix for sale and
distribution uh and basically it's
exactly what it sounds like it's
basically kool-aid that you just add
some water to and you can get smashed I
believe we have an image of some of the
packaging the Christian get a pot
cosmopolitan a mojito a powder Rita
which apparently tastes just like a
margarita and a lemon drop amongst a
couple others and there's been some
confusion on the internet whether this
was approved or wasn't approved which
seems like it's up to a bit of debate
the labels I guess haven't been approved
yet uh but uh would you drink powdered
alcohol is this the future is everything
gonna be in powdered form I feel very
conflicted because I don't drink bye
love novelty items so I feel like I kind
of want to have the powdered alcohol
just because it's ridiculous and like
you know it's a thing to do right would
you snort the powdered alcohol if you
don't drink as a non-drinker yeah no I
think that's a good loophole snorted or
like making a face mask out of it just
rub it into your skin yeah a little
paste whatever it takes whatever is I'm
gonna drink it not gonna drink it I just
think yeah anything that makes making
jungle juice for college parties easier
is going to succeed so I can't imagine I
i feel like the prank potential of
powdered alcohol is really high you know
just to like your friends away like it's
finally a fun surprise to leave in
someone's drink you know not a dangerous
one so you know you leave a little
powder rita in there and they get a nice
little surprise as they're having brunch
look at Sunday you know I could see
college kids across america it's the new
the new trend on campus yes remember a
couple was it like a year ago there was
going to be beer that was just a vapor
and you could just get wasted like that
people always fight this stuff but you
really can't fight progress can you one
day if people want to have a little
packet of powdered booze they're gonna
have it right
everything will be okay yeah also like
idea of sprinkling alcohol on your food
I love as a flavor enhancer or just to
get drunk on fries whatever it takes a
margarita french fries yet why not and
get drunk at the same time it's a
feature not a parable seem like the
future actually yeah he solved it um do
you think that they're gonna have you
know alternate companies they're going
to start cutting it with stuff you know
cuz there's there's a drug element to
this you know you mean where you're
gonna get the pure stuff and then it's
going to be cut with some some drano or
something right gasoline gasoline
whatever it is yeah yeah it's just I I
mean we really have the equivalent I'm
sure these things just tastes like bad
like wine mixer is basically like the
things the things they sell in like
pouches at you know CBS I was that all
the wine cooler brand like from the
eighties those two guys there's two old
guys bartels in jails in jail like it
would taste a lot exactly so it's just
it's that's my one problem with is like
do you need another step towards alcohol
like has anybody ever been like man I
love drinking but if only there was
another preparatory step between me and
getting drunk right I don't think they
stop and you it's actually better
because you to think about it you know
like you're gonna have another drink do
I really want to open this powder packet
and mix it with water right wait on that
time couldn't it also be the reverse of
that like where people want to get drunk
easily let's say you're at a baseball
game and you don't want to pay 12 bucks
for a beer and you can be like oh I got
a bottle of water well actually about
water probably Class A but you bring
your own water and then you know any
incident on its crystal light so
financially it makes sense sure if you
were didn't one time but I've just never
had like kool-aid and thought to myself
like man I wanna have koolaid more like
I want this to expand into other areas
of my life and so I don't the idea of
making alcoholic kool-aid doesn't
exactly like if you told me like hey I
made a bunch of alcoholic kool-aid would
you like some I would definitely say no
thing you would not try that so is this
really though it seems to me that this
is really about kids drinking cuz that's
where the you know like they can of
course they're gonna market it to adults
but the people that are really going to
be smuggling packets it to parties and
family event it's gonna be kids so there
is some risk I want this package like
Pixy Stix we can have a handful
and I guess I open my bed fund it's even
better oh that was your thinking outside
the box yeah no I want to use it as
alcoholic fun dip that actually is the
best that sounds great give me those
little white sugar sticks and yeah I
mean should be we be concerned though
about the kids the kids we should always
think it's always someone has to be
concerned about the kids you know what's
your name from the simpsons Lovejoy's
wife is over worried about kids it does
seem uh like this will be a very shop
lifted item like it's much easier to go
into a store and grab a little pouch of
something and that will fit in anybody's
pocket than to like grab a bunch of
bottles imagine kids like pockets full
of powder just like grabbing and for the
flower and walking around just like
leaving a trail of alcohol behind them
yeah it just has so much so many
occasional not good sounds like it's a
portmanteau of like pals and alcohol
which already is like oh no all right
well maybe the palcohol people have some
marketing issues to work on they still
gotta get the labels approved and
everything so we will see what happens
and when it becomes legal we will drink
it here and do official taste test